and finally to every person on social
media who's asked me since November bill
what do you have to say about Stanley
and every paparazzi outside a restaurant
who's still shouting at me bill what
about the Stanley thing okay your day
has come
tonight's editorial is about Stanley who
if you missed it died in November and a
few days later I posted a blog that was
in no way an attack on mr. Lee but took
the occasion of his death to express my
dismay at people who think comic books
are literature and superhero movies are
great cinema and who in general are
stuck in an everlasting childhood
bragging that you're all about the
Marvel Universe is like boasting that
your mother still pins your mittens to
your sleeves you can if you want like
the exact same things you liked when you
were 10 but if you do you need to grow
up
that was the point of my blog I'm not
glad Stan Lee is dead I'm sad you're
alive
[Applause]
and by the way if someone says you're
being childish and you react by throwing
a tantrum you're not iron man you're
ironing man well let me tell you people
were pissed about this post I wasn't
even aware that I had ruffled so many
capes until I saw that 40,000 Twitter
followers unfollowed me like that to
which I say good riddens follow Yogi
Bear
director Kevin Smith accused me of
taking a shot with no shots are [ __ ]
necessary except again my shot wasn't at
Stan Lee it was at you know grown men
who still dressed like kids
one comment said that Stanley has
inspired children to believe in
something bigger than them and then
added Congrats you're a [ __ ] on the same
level that Ann Coulter is a [ __ ] boy did
you pick the wrong night to tune in
[Laughter]
other people tweeted things like I
learned about social justice and racial
tolerance by reading comic books okay
but now you have pubic hair read James
Baldwin read Toni Morrison read Michael
Eric Dyson even a book as dumb as the
Bible gets this when I was a child I
spoke as a child I understood as a child
I thought as a child but when I became a
man I put away childish things including
my x-men bedsheets
can we stop pretending that the writing
in comic books is so good oh please
every superhero movies the same thing a
person who doesn't have powers gets them
has to figure out how they work and then
has to find a glowy thing Justice League
glowy thing Iron Man
glowy thing Spider Man glowy thing
Captain America glowy thing glowy thing
glowy thing glowy thing
and again there's nothing wrong with a
man writing comic books there is
something wrong with adults thinking
they're profound the folks at Stan's
company team Stan wrote an open letter
to me and said you have a right to your
opinion that comics are childish and
unsophisticated many said the same about
Dickens Steinbeck Melville and even
Shakespeare no they didn't no no one
ever said that no one ever said kingly
or a moby dick was childish and
unsophisticated if you ever read a book
without pictures you'd know that
seems Shakespeare just write you an open
letter yes Howard the Duck Hamlet same
diff
to thine own self be true meet Hulk
smash comics are for kids
that's why they sell them next to the
pokeyman cards and not on the aisle with
the condoms in the lube I'm sorry but if
you are an adult playing with superhero
dolls I'm sorry
I mean collectible action figures why
not go all the way and drive to work on
a big wheel grown-ups these days they
cling so desperately to their childhood
that when they do attempt to act their
age they have a special word for it now
adulting hey world look at me I just
made my own eye appointment hashtag
adulting eating vegetables adulting
today I wipe my own ass
I guess I'm turning into my dad
marriages have been destroyed because
the husband's adult men can't stop
playing video games when your wife wants
to have sex and you can't come to bed
because you're about to level up in
fortnight don't be surprised when your
relationship does this
you